the big story of the evening last night
and of the morning this morning
is this whole blow up over alexandra
ocasio-cortez's story with regard to the
january 6th riot
so we're going to break this down in all
of its aspects because
some of what she's saying is true much
of what the media is saying is not true
and this really goes to how our
fact-checking industry works our
fact-checking industry
here in the the information
dissemination space is extraordinarily
corrupt
extraordinarily corrupt and today is
like a classic story of how
our fact checkers get it wrong and they
get it wrong deliberately it's pretty
incredible
okay so let's begin at the beginning
january 6th riots happen
they're awful they're evil they're acts
of criminality alexander ocasio-cortez
this week she put out a 90-minute
instagram video in which she explained
her harrowing experiences and it would
not be difficult to conclude if you did
not know the geography of the area that
she was in the capitol building itself
now let's bring up a quick map okay
because capitol hill
actually is a bunch of places right
capitol hill is not just the capitol
building capitol hill
is a bunch of different places so for
example the
capitol hill built like the actual
capitol building
is not lo not all congressional offices
are actually located inside the capitol
building
some of the congressional offices are
located in what's called the longworth
building
another set of congressional offices are
located in the cannon building
alexander ocasio-cortez's offices are
in this map you can see the cannon house
office building
that is located all the way down first
street and across independence avenue
it's a little bit of a walk it's about
0.3 miles
it's not like right next door but it's
also not super duper far away
there are tunnels that connect the us
capital building to the cannon house
office building there's also the
longworth
longworth house office building and that
houses uh a bunch of
different congressional offices there's
also the rayburn house office building
right all of these are located
along independence avenue they are not
part of the capitol building they're
part of what's called the capital
complex meaning
that it includes you know everything in
the immediate area that is connected via
tunnels
okay so i've taken those tunnels they
exist
on the day of january 6th cannon house
office building was not breached
okay the riders did not breach canon
house office building did not breach the
longworth house office building they did
not breach the rayburn house office
building they breached the capitol
building itself
okay so if you watched aoc's live stream
she never says that she's in the capitol
building so let's be clear about this
she didn't lie and say that she was in
the capitol building some people are
saying that she lied
she didn't what she says is that she
felt like she was in imminent fear of
her life
okay and listen you are entitled to your
feelings it doesn't mean that your
feelings are entirely justified as we
will see
when you watch katie porter who is in
literally the same office because as he
ran to her office they seem to have very
different attitudes about what was going
down
that day here was alexander
ocasio-cortez describing her experiences
on the day of january 6th
and so i hide behind my door
like this like i'm here and the bathroom
door starts going like this
like the bathroom drawers behind me or
rather in front of me and i'm like this
and the door hinges right here
and i just hear where is she where is
she
and um this was the moment
where i thought
everything was over
okay and then she continued and it turns
out that the person who was banging on
her door was actually a capital police
officer now we know from the day of
the capitol police officers were in fact
getting people to
leave the cannon house building and move
to safer locations but ocasio-cortez
what she said
should continue on in that video she
said that after the capitol hill police
officer came into the office she said
quote things weren't adding up
like she added there was no partner
there and no one was yelling he wasn't
yelling like this is capital police
he was looking at me and all this anger
and hostility
she said did he not say he was capital
police on purpose was he trying to
actually put us in a vulnerable
situation
all these crazy thoughts go through your
mind are some offices safer than others
because they have white sounding names
or male sounding names okay so so this
is the way that she tells the story
okay now she heads on over to katie
porter's office which is
right next door so here is katie porter
on msnbc describing
the exact same set of circumstances
except from her perspective
first she you know she saw me um she and
we waved i went into my office and a
couple seconds later she knocked and
she said you know could we could we come
in and i said of course
um and she began to deal her staffer was
trying to describe what had happened
and alex is really usually like
unfailingly polite
um and very personable and she wasn't
even really talking to me she was
opening up doors and and i was like can
i help you
like what are you looking for and she
said i'm looking for where i'm going to
hide
okay so here is the thing katie porter's
reaction when alexander ocasio-cortez
burst in is not okay let's get in here
let's barrier up all the doors
they're out there they're coming it's
like what's going on now
oh why why are you doing this okay so is
katie porter reacting inappropriately
i don't think so in fact aoc describes
how she walks in i believe
and katy porter's sipping coffee right
and so and and then katie porter is
being told by aoc i'm looking for a
place to hide and aoc is saying i'm
afraid i'm going to die today i always
wanted to be a mother
and then apparently aoc didn't have
sneakers she was wearing high heels
and so she said to katie porter do you
have any sneakers and katie porter went
to one of her staffers and had her give
her her sneakers which like
imagine you're that staffer like if you
actually think that the danger is that
grave outside and it's like okay
you know staffer i know that you're
wearing sneakers right now
but let's be real about this aoc has a
lot of instagram fans and you are a
no-name staffer in katie porter's office
i'm gonna need you to give those
sneakers to
ocasio cortez because let's be real here
she has huge twitter following i mean
the woman has an enormous media presence
and you
you you anonymous staffer you just have
sneakers so you know what i'm gonna need
you to turn over those speakers okay
those sneakers in any case what aoc says
is not actually lying right so i've said
this already
her emotional response may not be well
calibrated
i mean that's possible or maybe it's
really well calibrated and maybe she's
just maybe that's how she responds
emotionally people respond emotionally
in crisis circumstances
differently okay to give everybody the
benefit of the doubt some people react
like katie porter does and they sit
there and they're like i don't even
what and some people react like aoc and
have a heightened sense of panic
fair okay that's okay you're allowed to
do that for sure
hey nancy mays who is two doors down the
representative she said aoc made clear
she didn't know who was at her door
breathless attempts by the media to fan
fictitious news flames are dangerous she
said my office is two doors down
insurrectionists never stormed our
hallway egregious doesn't even begin to
cover it
is there nothing the msm won't
politicize because here's the way that
newsweek
covered what aoc said here's newsweek
ocasio-cortez said rioters actually
entered her office forcing her to take
refuge inside her bathroom
after her legislative director geraldo
benia chavez told her to hide hide
run and hide as members of the mob
banged against the door ocasio-cortez
believed that this was the moment where
i thought everything was over okay so
the media
immediately spin up aoc's story she
didn't lie again
aoc's original statement maybe and
maybe a uh in out of out of proportion
emotional response to the events that
were actually happening immediately
surrounding her that's not a lie
it doesn't make it a lie the media
immediately begins spinning this up the
media immediately begins spinning this
into
alexander ocasio-cortez was in her
office the writers were right outside
her office they were trying to bang down
the doors now
here is the thing why was alexander
acosta's ocasio-cortez's story
leading the news for several days here
and there were several washington post
editorials about how brave she was and
how wondrous she was
why was she leading the news of all the
people who had relevant stories to tell
on january 6th
she is like somewhere near the bottom of
the list because again she was not in
the capital building itself there were
legislators who are in the capitol
building itself
if you were looking for personal
harrowing experiences presumably you
would start with them just to be
completely objective and fair you would
start with the people who are in the
most immediate physical danger and then
you would move on down the list right
but that's not the way that the media
treated this and the media treated this
this way because alexander ocasio-cortez
is willing to say completely unhinged
things
not about her own personal experiences
per se but she's willing to say unhinged
things
about other people right so she will
just throw out implications like ted
cruz wanted to murder me
or like ted cruz and josh halley are
just like the person who sexually
assaulted me and the media lapped this
crap up
the media want to make that the number
one story they love the implication
right so they don't fact check where she
was at the time that's not important
what is important to the media is the
stuff that is not fact checkable
meaning her implication which is that
all republicans are incipient murderers
who wanted her personally killed
and or are like rapists who want their
victims to just forgive and forget
right that's the part that the media
loves that's why the media spun it up
if alexander ocasio-cortez he just
described her circumstance and said
listen i was in the
cannon house office building it's
located about .3 miles away it's like a
six-minute walk there's some capital
tunnels but those were protected by cops
building wasn't breached at any point
but i was i was in fear because i know
that i'm really famous and i know a lot
of people send me death threats and it
freaks me out so when that happened
i went and i hid in katie porter's
office and listen i was scared
do you think that would have made the
same headlines of course it wouldn't
have made the same headlines the reason
it became a headline is because
she said she was a sexual assault
survivor and therefore
the people who were not on her political
side of the aisle that she dislikes are
just like
the person who sexually assaulted her
right that's why it made headlines
that's why you got the
bravery of alexandra ocasio-cortez
routine
from the media that's the reason not
because of the actual circumstances
that surrounded her and this is why you
have a piece from
thelily.com saying in alexander
ocasio-cortez these survivors found a
voice
i felt with her the deeply vulnerable
pain of telling someone
right this was also linked by the
washington post ocasio-cortez's explicit
language around trauma may help
facilitate other women's healing
experts added and so is all the
ancillary stuff that aoc said which
really truly was i believe immoral i
don't think that comparing
fellow fellow congress people to rapists
is a useful enterprise i don't think
suggesting that ted cruz wants you dead
is a useful enterprise but the media
love that kind of stuff right that is
the reason
why her account became the account
okay so over the course of last night a
bunch of people pointed out
by the way she wasn't in the capitol
building and
the and some people went
further and said you know and that means
that she was exaggerating what she was
what she was saying she was exaggerating
her experiences again
she she could have legitimately felt
what she was feeling doesn't mean the
feeling was totally justified but she
could certainly have felt that
i'm not doubting the veracity of her
feelings at the time and her account
is accurate so far as i can tell she she
just it's somewhat misleading in that
if you are reacting as though there are
capital rioters directly at your door
and the closest they are is three tenths
of a mile away and you are protected by
several layers of police
it's not quite the same thing right and
you can see why people would draw that
conclusion like the entire media drew
the conclusion that she was actually in
the middle
of sort of the most dangerous area here
from from her description
so here's what happens this starts to
trend right
on twitter the hashtag alexandra
ocasiosmole
starts the trend as in jesse smelly
right the jesse smallett the
the actor who described how he was how
he was
lynched with the noose in the streets of
chicago by a couple of maga hat guys and
it turns out to be complete nonsense now
that's an exaggeration in and of itself
right i mean she's not
jesse smallette she didn't claim that
the rioters had bust in there
and she describes her feelings
throughout the ordeal and you can think
that those feelings are unjustified
i i hear that but her feelings are her
feeling it doesn't mean she lied
i keep saying that over and over because
i want to be very clear about what is
true and what is false unlike the fact
checkers we're going to get to in just
one second
so here is where alexandra ocasio-cortez
starts to really
lose it okay so she sends out an email
to from team aoc to her entire email
list
and her email asks her constituents to
contact
anybody in the fact-checking world or in
the social media world and try to get
them to censor and remove tweets that
suggest that she was not in the capitol
building
hey i'm serious here's what she wrote as
we speak right-wing operatives with
millions of followers on social media
are spreading flat out lies and
misleading information about alexandria
but with your help we can force twitter
and facebook to take action
and enforce their own rules what's so
frustrating about these attacks is that
once the truth comes out so few people
get to hear it hundreds of thousands or
potentially millions of people who have
already seen or shared the misleading
tweets or fake news articles okay so
first of all
the irony of alexander ocasio-cortez a
person who has said on national
television
that actual facts matter less than moral
truth
there is some irony here this is a
person who has spent the entire
the entirety of the last several weeks
claiming without evidence that fellow
congress people so far as i'm aware
she's provided no evidence of this that
fellow congress people
were in on the riots that ted cruz
wanted her murdered attempted to have
her murdered that josh halley and ted
cruz are like her own sexual assaulters
and here she is being like i can't
believe people are putting out
misleading information
that's really upsetting but here's where
it gets dicey what is the misleading
information
okay apparently the misleading
information is that
she was not in the capital building so
she keeps insisting that she was in the
capitol building
because in fact she was part of the
capital complex right this is what she
tweets out
she tweets out well you know guys i mean
it's connected by tunnels
she says this is the latest manipulative
take on the right they're manipulating
the fact that most people don't know the
layout of the capital complex we were
all on the capitol complex
the attack wasn't just on the dome the
bombs trump supporters planted
surrounded our offices too okay so a
couple of things there
one we have yet to find the evidence of
who actually planted the bombs
she can make an assumption it was trump
supporters but that actually is not
publicly available information
so that in and of itself is misleading
information
and when she says that we were part of
the capital complex and therefore
they were trying to attack the capital
complex in general
nancy mace was on the same floor she
says the rioters did not breach the
building
okay reporters at the time said the
writers did not breach that building
again this is not to say that she
couldn't have been justified or at least
she couldn't have felt legitimately and
authentically in danger
again people react to crisis in
different ways but what she is now
saying which is that
oh yeah you know people are saying i
wasn't in the capitol building how dare
they
well i mean were you or were you not in
the in in the capitol building
it's called the capital building it's
not called the capital complex when
people say
the rioters stormed at the capitol
building they mean the capital
building like a building because
they don't mean the complex right i mean
so so she is now
now she's misleading so she puts out a
this email and she says
we need your help here's what you can do
to help us combat this campaign of
disinformation and others in the future
scan your social media to find posts
with this misleading information
especially those using the trending
hashtag
it's funny how alexander ocasio-cortez
is you know her emergency mode kicks in
when she's trending for the wrong
reasons on twitter right as somebody who
trends on twitter frequently like once
every
three weeks once every month i can tell
you that the best thing you can do with
a twitter trend is basically ignore it
that's pretty much the best thing you
can do with the twitter's one but she
is uh instead she says she wants all of
her followers to basically spam facebook
and twitter and get a bunch of stuff
taken down
which is not a great look for a sitting
congress person she says don't tweet any
hashtags yourself because we don't want
them to spread further
identify any posts that are threatening
or harassing and use the built-in report
features
to flag them for the moderators facebook
and twitter both have built-in tools
for reporting posts and tweets that
break the rules
the sad thing is that a lot of damage
has already been done people have
already been misled and radicalized they
believe the lies to a point where their
hatred could someday boil over into
violence ah so now she's going to say
that if you point out that she was not
in the capitol building
itself that you are one of the kinds of
people who distributes information that
ends with the january 6th riots
i mean that's that's pretty manipulative
stuff right there
she says we can keep calling out
photoshop tweets fake news articles
misleading posts when we see them okay
now here is where the fact checkers get
involved okay so it used to be that fact
checkers
checked fact right that was the thing
that they used to check
was the facts not implications they
didn't fact check
emotional suggestions they didn't check
fact check
subjective takes what they used to fact
check
was you know facts and there are many
things that could be fact checked here
so for example you could fact-check
whether she was actually in the capitol
building at the time
or you could fact-check whether she lied
at the shoes in the capitol building at
the time
right the answer on the first issue was
not in the capitol building at the time
and two
i don't see evidence that she lied about
being in the capitol building at the
time and both of those things can
simultaneously be true but that is not
what the fact checkers do
because the fact checkers are just
democratic operatives they are just
completely full of crap so here is how
the fact checkers do their business
this is how they have decided that
they're going to pervert the system and
understand it matters what the fact
checkers do
because when we are talking about how
you receive information
you will see that sites like facebook
and like twitter they use
left wing fact checkers in order to
knock down right wing
sites knock down conservative sites and
those left-wing fact-checkers are taken
as though they are objective
metrics for the news that facebook was
using
during the month after the election they
were using what they called their their
trusted news metric it's like this is
quality news metric and the way that
they measured that is they went to
basically a bunch of left-wing fact
checkers and then they would downgrade
any news source that got fact checked a
lot
so naturally cnn never got fact checked
but daily water got fact-checked a lot
because it turns out that the people at
places like snopes and politifact
hate the daily wire but love cnn because
it's all subjective
and so here is the fact check from
snopes it's a perfect example
of how the fact checkers are just they
just lie by implication
and sometimes openly it's pretty amazing
okay so snopes puts out a piece
on this whole silly debacle right here's
what they say
did aoc exaggerate the danger she was in
during the capital riot
okay so first of all you can't
fact-check that there's literally no way
to fact-check
that particular question because that is
a matter of subjective opinion
did aoc exaggerate the danger she was in
during the capital riot
so you could say no she didn't
exaggerate the danger that she was in
during the capital riot because the
capital rioters were violent they were
looking for congress people
theoretically they could have gotten in
and it could have hurt her or you could
say no she absolutely exaggerated the
danger she was in considering no one
breached that building there were other
congress people on that level none of
them are acting like aoc did
so maybe she did exaggerate so there's
really no way to fact-check that right
that is a subjective matter of opinion
whether alexander ocasio-cortez
exaggerated the physical danger they
choose in
in the account that she told of what was
going on
now again there are fact-checkable
things that snopes could do here they
don't do that they frame the question
as a fact check about emotional response
you can't fact-check emotional response
which is why i have said over and over
and over
that aoc did not lie right that is a
fact check aoc did not lie
okay you may think that her emotional
response is off killed her that does not
that does not mean that she lied right
there are ways to fact check that are
objective
that's not what the fact checkers are
doing so says aoc was targeted with
another round of bad faith smears
after giving an emotional firsthand
account of her experiences during the
capital riot
okay so let's get to the actual fact
check from snopes because it is so
indicative
of how exactly snopes and these fact
checkers operate
so here's what they do they say claim
this is snopes fact check of the whole
aoc
silliness claim alexander ocasio-cortez
exaggerated the danger she was in during
the january 6
2021 capital riot and that she quote
wasn't even in the capitol building when
the rioting occurred
okay well those are two claims that you
are now fact-checking and you are
lumping them together
so that you can pretend that a factual
claim is a non-factual claim
right there's two claims that snopes is
now fact-checking one is that she
exaggerated the danger that is not
fact-checkable and the other is a
fact-checkable statement that she was
not
in the capital building when the rioting
occurred it is true she was not in the
capitol building when the rioting
occurred how do i know this
because snopes acknowledges this here is
what snopes says
first of all they say it's mostly false
okay the claim is alexander
ocasio-cortez exaggerated the danger she
was in during the january 6 2021 capital
riot and that she wasn't even in the
capital building when the rioting
occurred
rating mostly false mostly false okay
here's what they say
what's true ocasio-cortez wasn't in the
main capital building where the house
and senate chambers are located
wait what now so literally you are
fact-checking the question of whether
she was in the capitol building
and then you say it's true she wasn't in
the capital building but you rate the
claim
mostly false here's the best part of
this i love this so
they fact checked one of the tweets that
came from daily wire because of course
the idea here is to keep
dinging and downgrading conservative
sources even when they are telling
the objective truth so here is the daily
wire tweet that they called misleading
why is it misleading by the way it's
misleading because the conservative side
put it out here is what the daily wire
tweeted
you ready for this this is what they are
fact-checking as misleading quote
report aoc was not inside capital
building during breach on january 6th
that's the entirety of the tweet report
aoc was not inside capital building
during breach on january 6th now let me
read to you again
from what snopes says is true quote
ocasio-cortez wasn't in the main capitol
building
why it's almost as though it's true when
you say it but misleading when i say it
so you're just full of that's the
that's the impression i'm getting from
you snopes like i'm getting the
impression that you fact checkers very
often are more interested
in fact-checking implications than
fact-checking facts because you want to
come up with a pre-ordained
conclusion and that is that anyone who
criticizes alexander or casa cortez
isn't just wrong
they are a liar they are saying untruths
right that no that is not the way any of
this works but this is a dangerous thing
that is happening right now in the
country
because what you are seeing i've been
talking about this for a while these
shift
from disinformation to misinformation
right it's just it's misinformation you
know it's like it's just it's it's
information we don't like
that shift is so dangerous and what the
left has been doing what the fact
chapters have been doing what the social
media sites have been doing
is they've been fact checking
implications whenever you see a fact
check that says
needs context you know this is now a
political it's now a political exercise
because either a claim is true or it's
not when you say that a claim it needs
context that is a claim
that i will discuss on the show right i
mean that's what the show is for is to
give context to various claims
we'll discuss it but context is a
political argument there are various
takes on what context is appropriate to
place things in
there are certain things in life that
are factually true and certain things in
life that are factually false it is
factually true alexander alcazar cortez
was not
in the capitol building then there is
the secondary claim which is
did she exaggerate what happened to her
and there you have to really examine her
emotional response was it appropriate
for the time how are other people
at the area responding right all of that
is a matter of opinion
but instead what the fact checkers do is
they wrap all that up in a ball and then
call it false
a thing that is objectively true which
is that she was not in the capital
building at the time now why am i making
a big deal out of this
i'm making a big deal out of it for a
couple of reasons one the manipulation
of truth actually matters it matters an
awful lot
and when you say that there are
fact-checking sites that are out there
to fact-check
and when you say that objective truth is
really just your opinion
that is orwellian kind of stuff the
redefinition of truth to mean anything i
like
and the redefinition of falsehoods mean
anything that i disagree with
is a dangerous thing especially when you
have the mechanistic power when you have
the institutional power
to ram down your version of truth
meaning your opinion on everybody else
that is a dangerous dangerous thing it
also happens to be that the media have
people that they love and the fact
characters have people that they love
and they will manipulate these stats in
order to achieve
a given end you see the you see this
with joe biden if joe biden lies or
gensacki lies it's not a lie it just
requires a little bit of context you're
just not getting the full idea
and if republicans say something that is
true
but has the wrong implications according
to the media it becomes a missing
context or mostly false statement
and then that is used to downgrade your
ability to access the information
it is a mind f okay that is what is
going on right now
and it's it's really something that we
all need to watch out for
because it's it's again when this stuff
is used to censor
when you have by the way active congress
people sitting in the federal government
asking for censorship of claims that
they don't like
that happen to be true that's that is
not a good look that is not a good look
at all facts don't care about your
feelings and it's a fact that the ben
shapiro show is the largest conservative
podcast in the nation
be sure to hit the subscribe button to
stay up to date on all of our content